I started our relationship with just
paying all the time I I paid for
everything we'd go out for dinner I
would pay um I already had a a place
where I lived that I paid for and uh you
know etc etc so I I understand how I've
kind of set a pattern um think I'm just
trying to figure out if um if I'm being
taken advantage of is this just
something where I'm I'm being you know
I've brought something up several times
and I just nothing changed es nothing it
just stays the same this this is this
isn't a money issue this is a respect
issue you don't respect the man that
you're married
to because like I I bring
home I I I bring home a quote unquote
income to the house but my wife my God
Almighty if she disappeared the house
would go away so I don't look at her and
say wow you're not contributing to this
thing and I'm paying for dinner all the
time